>>> GOOD MO VIEWERS HERE.S. ANAR
FOUR PEOPLE ARE DEAD THI THREEEM
SHOOALL BU
DO
EGAN YESTERDAY
MORNING AND CONTINUETHLA LELTERZ
THEIR OWN SAFETYNTT WAS .
THIS IS NOAYOR
AND IT IS ACCEPTABLE. ES19-YEAR
A HIGH-SPE
TH T
SUSPWA TED GR
GUILTY TE LESSER CHARGE OFN OF
BUORBE  T  S,
TENNESSEE, WITH THE LATEST
GARY, WHAT CAN YOU TEL
ELL,D
NIGHT THA
TERRORIZED AND PAL
PE WHO LIVE HERE IE CITY
DOWNTOWN MEMPHIS. ACTE I
STREET DOINGE RT W FOR,
A TEACHER WHO WAS KIDNAPON
WAS FOUND WE SAW PCA
SOINN  UP D DO REALIZED
WERNINBLE. PEOPLE DEADREAST THR
SUSPEC THE STATE
LIMISSSI I
AWAY FROME,OLE A VEHICL TRIPTIE
THIS WAS PUT ON FACEBOOKPART OF,
LKING
TCAUSE YE T AS I, EADED
CHGEATEDAU
AFTER BEIND WITH EEUTON T
MARC
HE WAS SUPPOSED TO BE YOR, AS Y,
UPT AT IF MR.  HIS
THREE-YEAR SENTENCE, HE WOULD
STILISON TODAY
FOLLOW CITIZENS
L BE ALIVE.
>> Reporter:SHL KELLY SHOWM
E  HISATAL H
LAST NIGHT,  SHUT THALT TON WATT
E NEARBYNDUNDED ON THE DOOR TO
TH TO YOU. HASE  MUCH, GARY, TH
ITH US THIEN
MORNING.
FIRST I WANT TO ASK ABOUT THE
MANHR THISTHEY HAD A IN PLAC
ORDER, TY SHUT CIT
AS THEY WENTM CRIME
CRIME SCENE.
HOW UNUSUAL IS T
SOIN'S THERA
UNPRECEDENTE
G WHER
EWWAS ON THE DIWE ASKED PEOPLE .
U'LL, OF COURSE, REMEMBER THE OR
F YO ED THE CIRCL THOSE
TW
IT'S A THING CS HATE TO DO I RES
S  SIC REALLY SAID, EVERYONE JU
STAY INSIDE AN LASTED
ALSO WANT  ABOUT
THE MAYOR WAS SAYINGS
SUSPECT WHO HA CHARG
WITHATD  PLED GUILTY
AVAD
1 MONT-YEAR
MAYOR THERAM
ONHES CRIME S ALLOWED TO
>> WELL, SEEIN
E AT
HAVING THIS
VIOLENCE.N PO INDIVIDUALS WI LDS
KIDNAPERWHS KIDNAPPED OFF THRENT
OF JAIL FOR KIAP AND RAPE